by a vote of 6 to 1 Jonathan you are
evicted from the Big Brother house
Jonathan Bennett yep first to go ha ha
what happened
first of all nailed it it was perfect
secondly don't have Olympic gold
medalist Ryan Lochte pick you as his
pick to be in the first competition of
Big Brother because you will get the
biggest target on your back I mean it
was I'm so glad because I love Ryan so
much I became best friends and so I have
a friend for life but when you have an
Olympic swimmer athlete at you know gold
medalist as your partner it just if
people are gonna come after you and
that's what happened and you know I'm ok
with that I should have I should have
picked Dina and put her up on the Block
I should have done that and you know
what I just can't do that because I know
I need to protect her because you know
she's like a mama you got to protect
mama Lohan in the house hey Lindsey
would come after me and you don't want
Lindsey to come after you so like Lohan
if you're watching Lindsey I saved mama
as much as I could but now she's on her
own so I hope she wins she's got a few
more weeks in there hopefully yeah I
think she would win like what if what if
the genius part of all this is that Vita
Lohan wins Celebrity Big Brother like
come on I will be watching every week
genius see what happens do you know who
the one vote that wasn't for you was no
I don't who was it Dina Dina Dina I love
you you can't even watch this just block
the way man it doesn't even matter
whatever Dina yes that is awesome but
you know it's really shocking because
those girls they're interesting you know
it was it was like a real-life Mean
Girls in the house I was like having
flashbacks to being on the set of Mean
Girls in The Celebrity Big Brother house
so it was it was interesting and you
know like Dina came to me and literally
just goes
Mean Girls watch out and she was right
mama always knows don't align with them
I was gonna say did you have any inkling
today that this was gonna happen that
you are gonna be out the door I really
thought that Joey was gonna go home and
then he was safe and I was like whoa and
I was like well then oh I have to walk
I'm I'm going home great like it was it
was really interesting and now you get
to go home to get to go home watch all
of this yep play out who do you think is
the next big target in that house I
think the biggest target is either low
low or Taytay and I would say Ryan
because he's a threat but low low has
just done ticked off a lot of people in
there she her attitude is not cute right
now in that house and I think people are
gonna come after her okay I think for
the good of the house one of the one of
the explosive energies in there needs to
get out in my opinion okay okay
looking ahead there's still a lot of
game left to play yeah but I've got to
call it right now who wins this
honestly and you know what she has been
there for her kids for so many years she
has always put the focus on all of her
children and making them have so much
success and lifting them up for so many
years that it wouldn't be great if Dina
wins and it kind of comes back to her
and this is her moment to shine because
she's let her kids trying so much that
maybe this is her turn we're kind of
getting to meet Dina for the first time
so hey it would be cherry on top of this
experience yeah you told Julie this was
the greatest experience of your life
yeah why it's the greatest and the worst
experience of my life I'm not gonna lie
it's insane but it's also amazing like
when do you ever have
you know what 15 days since we went in
to Questor where you're not allowed to
use your phone or talk to anyone else
like you learn a lot about yourself and
it's amazing but it's also awful at the
lake not bad just like you're stuck in a
house with all these people you don't
know and there's tempers and angers and
energy and negativity all being thrown
at you so you have to get your armor on
and learn how to deflect all that and so
you learn a lot about yourself and so
it's amazing but also like I got to
swing from the rafters like Tarzan
against Olympic gold medalist Ryan
Lochte like how cool is that you got to
check off a lot of Big Brother and
things know your advantages yeah I'm
huge
and I got to eat slop like I ring the
bell because let's go back for a second
first of all are you my Mac Jonathan
Bennett has been in the house for ten
days what has he done won the HOH
competition lost an HOH competition
played a veto ceremony lost or played a
veto competition lost the veto
competition went on slop played another
veto competition lost it has been on the
block I think the longest ever in
history of Celebrity Big Brother I have
been on the block the longest like talk
about a jam-packed ten days you can't do
any more in ten days like I've done
everything there is to do
at all yeah is there anything you would
have done differently though other than
you said kind of maybe not aligned with
Ryan right don't align with the biggest
target the house within the first four
hours that could be a better game play
strategy but the only thing I would have
done different is what I tried to do
which is talk less smile more but at the
same time I'm Who I am
and I'm gonna tell everyone everything
and talk to people because I like people
and I like making people laugh and I
like talking to them and I like being
likable to people because I watch I want
everyone to be happy and so there are a
lot of moments I could have not you know
given them the answers to things but I
did it I chose to be a teammate and
clearly they don't understand what a
team is so when y'all get out we're
gonna school you on teamwork all right
another big brother thing you got to
check off was a major twist yes
scaramouche II never in the history of
my life
would I say that I showered next to
Anthony scaramouche II like I'd be in
the shower talking to him while he's
shaving and it was became the most
normal thing in the world and I'm like
wait did I just have a full blown
conversation with Anthony scare Moochie
while he shaves and I shower in a
bathroom like that is just bizarre and
what couldn't have been a nicer amazing
guy like I was so glad to meet him for
him and not what you read about him you
know it was really cool but he wasn't
even a houseguest big brother you're
gone you're really good you have any
predictions for what those future
breaking news
celebrity news twists are gonna be my
future prediction is that I'm gonna come
back and there's gonna be a twist where
someone that's been voted off number one
gets to re-enter halfway through and
make a decision
could you imagine that twist okay put it
out in the universe make it happen you
get to go home
yup to your real life right after this
what's the first thing you're gonna do
I'm going to Disneyland no I'm gonna
call scare Moochie and tell him that he
got me and then I am going to what am I
gonna do right now I've never I don't
know I guess I should eat something that
isn't slop that be agar agar you get to
be free I'm gonna do it on my cell phone
there you go Wow that'll be fun have you
had to go back and do it all again what
yes yes yes you say that what's my
validation I can't tell if I would do it
again or not I think I would yes I would
do it again but as far as like winners I
Brian you'll never see this do you get
out bro watch your back the Mean Girls
are coming for you watch out
you